Here's a crazy concept. The smarter you
get at your job, the worse you may be
getting at explaining it to somebody
else.
This is known as the curse of knowledge,
and it may quietly be costing you sales,
clients, credibility.
In this video, I'm going to show you how
to fix that. The idea of the curse of
knowledge is that you get to know
something so well that you actually
forget what it was like when you didn't
know that thing.
For example, if you were asked to
verbalize to somebody, tell them how to
tie a shoe,
that might be tougher than it seems. If
you could just use your words to explain
to somebody how you go about tying a
shoe, you'd really have to slow down and
think about every single step because
we've been doing it so long that we've
just internalized and it's become second
nature.
And this is a mistake many speakers
make. They give presentations to groups,
and they assume that everyone in the
room knows about 80% of what it is that
they're talking about.
In reality, that percentage probably
should be flipped, and it's likely that
they maybe only know 20% of what you're
talking about.
And you always want to assume that the
audience knows a little bit less and
then ease into these things so you don't
leave many audience members behind.
Now, of course,
there may be exceptions to this. You If
you're presenting to a room full of your
peers, maybe everyone's knowledge is at
a good space. But, what's far more
common is that audiences don't know the
information, and then they get really
left behind in technical jargon and
these ideas, or they may even feel bad
about themselves that they don't know
the information. And so, it's much
better to slow down, to check in with
the audience from time to time, and
ensure you are not losing them
by the curse of knowledge. If you're
presenting highly technical information
to an audience, and there is a risk that
they may not know exactly what you're
talking about,
I challenge you to use more analogies.
So, an example of this is something Gary
Vaynerchuk has been doing recently, and
he's talking about the importance of
consistency in posting content. And what
Gary says is that many people have come
to him and said, "Gary, I don't know
what's going on. I post five times a
week, and I'm not seeing results on my
social media. I'm not seeing growth. I'm
not seeing customer acquisition."
And what Gary does as an analogy is he
will get down on stage, and he will do
five push-ups. And then he'll stand up,
and he'll say, "What's going on? Why
aren't my muscles any bigger?"
And his point is that the volume has to
increase a lot, just like push-ups. You
have to do quite a few more push-ups to
see results
over time, consistency.
And that is a good analogy for knowing
how often you should be posting on
social media, and what your content
strategy should look like.
Or perhaps you're trying to explain
compounding interest to somebody,
you could use the example of a snowball
rolling down the hill. And over time, as
it gets bigger and bigger, and more snow
sticks to it, and it continues to grow,
it's actually going to go faster and
faster and faster. And that might be a
good analogy for somebody to visualize,
okay, this is the same concept behind
compounding interest.
So, anytime you're presenting to an
audience, know that there's a good
chance they might not have the same
technical expertise as you, and
analogies can help close that gap very
quickly. If you're giving a presentation
or sharing a point within a presentation
that is a bit technical in nature,
one good challenge is to try to
summarize
that overall umbrella concept with one
sentence.
So, what can happen sometimes is that we
get bogged down on all the different
things that we want to talk about that
is important to us, but may not be
important to the audience who we are
communicating to.
For example, if we have an amazing
product that can do 16 different things,
it might be tempting to
just verbalize all of those things. Hey,
it does this, and it does this, and it
does this, and it can do that.
But, that is overwhelming and may just
cause the audience's head to spin versus
summarizing it into one sentence. Hey,
this product, it's going to save you 5
hours of time per week.
And then helping the audience to think
like what could you do with those actual
5 hours that you get back?
That's the next step, but just being
able to summarize into one sentence. Or,
perhaps you're part of a customer
support team, and there's been a client
who was overcharged,
and there's a complex reason to why that
happened.
Well, sometimes as that customer service
rep, it might be tempting to explain,
"Okay, so we got we got to the bottom of
this. Here's what happened. There was an
error in our billing system, and then
this triggered this email that you got,
which got you upset, and that caused you
to reach out to us."
And you can go into all these details,
or
you can say,
"This was a bit of a complex situation,
but here's what you need to know. You
were overcharged. We're fixing it."
Simple. You've summarized the point. And
I believe that this is a strong strategy
anytime you're presenting something
where there is a risk that not every
member of the audience will be able to
follow or understand based on the
technical information.
So you always want to assume that your
audience knows a little bit less than
maybe what you think they know because
many people go the other way and assume
that the audience knows much more about
the information than they actually do.
But then from there, really try to
simplify points into one simple sentence
that the audience will remember once
they leave the room. One of the things I
love to teach those who I coach for
public speaking is the idea of a
five-point speech structure.
And the reason for this is that it
allows a complex idea to really be
simplified. And the five points are
this. Point number one is your intro. So
the first thing you say when you're on
stage or you're on a virtual call, what
is the thing you're using to grasp the
audience's attention right away?
The next three points represent the
body. So point one of the body, point
two of the body, point three of the
body. So if you are presenting on a
product that is amazing, perhaps you
lump this into three main points of why
the product is great and that will be
the next three points on your speech.
And then the final piece of the
five-point speech structure is the
conclusion. So how you bring everything
together and my favorite way to conclude
a speech is by making it come full
circle.
By
taking on this five-point speech
structure, especially if you're
presenting on something that is a little
bit complicated or complex for the
audience to understand, it forces you to
simplify it into a few different key
ideas and this will make you have a much
better chance of connecting with the
audience and having them remember what
you talked about after the presentation.
Many people who present technical
information are guilty of using slides
that have way too much information in
way too small of text.
So, I've seen this from various
companies or executives where they'll
pull up spreadsheets on the slide
presentation and they'll be walking
through the numbers and they'll
literally have their back turned to the
audience as they read off of a screen.
And there are so many reasons that is
not engaging. You're eliminating so much
body language, vocal variety. It seems
like you were not an expert in the
subject matter because you are reading
off of the screen just as the audience
is.
This is not an effective way of
presenting. And so, my challenge is if
you have a data-rich presentation or a
lot of numbers that you need to go over,
still just use your slides
to have only a few words, ideally mostly
visuals, that reinforce the key points.
What is the key thing you want your
audience members to take away from all
of this data?
That is what should be on the slide in
big letters, like a 100-point font, and
very few words on the screen. And if
it's absolutely necessary that your
audience needs to have access to all of
these spreadsheets and data, then
consider having that information printed
off and given to them afterward or in
advance,
but don't bog down your presentation.
When you're trying to teach your
audience something or get an idea to
really sink in with them, if you have a
bunch of numbers on the screen with text
that nobody can read because they're
trying to squint and the numbers are too
small, that is not doing anything for
your presentation. The final thing that
is essential for any technical
presentation you're giving is observing
the audience while you're speaking.
And look for cues that things are either
sinking in or perhaps seeing that
there's some confusion on your
audience's faces.
If they're staring blankly at the screen
that you have on the wall, the
projector, and they look confused or
they're looking at you like they're
puzzled and they have that furrowed brow
or that type of look on their face,
that may be a clear sign that something
is not sinking in. And so that's your
opportunity as a speaker to to check in
with with everyone. Is this making sense
so far?
Is I I see some confusion on the faces.
And you can actually ask certain people
like that point sink in for you? Do you
have any questions about what I just
talked about?
You are much better to slow down on your
presentation and check in with your
audience
and risk maybe having to skip over
something in the future than you are to
just power through all of your
information if it's not sinking in with
the audience. Cuz in that case, they're
going to get zero value from the
presentation.
But if you're actively looking and you
can see, all right, the audience is
nodding, they're smiling, they're taking
notes,
that's a sign that things are probably
sinking in for them. And so this is
really important and it's a difficult
skill because as speakers we're we're
worried about our presentation, how is
everything sounding, are we getting all
the information we wanted to talk about,
but the best speakers are the ones who
are able to observe while they present
and ensure their audience isn't falling
behind. I hope this video on how to
really effectively give a technical
presentation was beneficial to you.
If this was something that was
beneficial, consider subscribing to my
channel. This is one of the best ways
you can stay connected and continue to
learn tips on public speaking. YouTube
is also suggesting a video for you to
check out. And I want you to go to the
links below my video because I have a
stand store with various offerings.
Because if you are serious, if you are a
leader or an executive,
or in any role
where you want to get more serious about
your public speaking and see significant
strides,
let's connect. Work with me and I will
help you get there fast. Thanks so much
for watching this video.